Speaker 1: The next question is okay. Trump was
given this framework by attorney John Eastman.
Here's how Pence could overturn the election. We
now know. On January 4th, Eastman said to Trump,
This plan is illegal. Okay, let's dig a
little more into that. When did Eastman know
that it was illegal? Well, he seemed to know
it very, very thoroughly and significantly.
We're going to look at a clip here. Former
Trump White House lawyer Eric Hirschmann
says he spoke with Eastman on January 7th and
told him you'd better get a great f ing criminal
defense lawyer because you're going to need it.
Not long after that, Eastman started asking for a
pardon from Donald Trump. He knew his suggestion
was criminal. Let's take a look at this clip.
Speaker 4: Mr. Hershman, account of that call.
Speaker 3: The day after my. He's
been I don't remember why he called me or he
texted me or called me one to talk with me.
He said he couldn't reach others. And he started
to ask me about something dealing with Georgia
and preserving something potentially for appeal.
And I said to him, Are you out of your f in mind?
I said I can. I only want to hear two words coming
out of your mouth. For now on. Orderly transition.
Mm hmm. There's rumors said I don't wanna hear
any other f ing words coming out of your mouth
no matter what, other than orderly transition.
Repeat those words to me. And I assume that
eventually you said orderly transition. I said,
good job. Now I'm going to give you the best free
legal advice you're ever getting in your life. Get
a great F in criminal defense lawyer. You're going
to need it, right? And then I hung up on him.
Speaker 1: He knew they all knew that this was
criminal, what they were trying to do. And then we
also now have, thanks to the committee, the email
we have an email from Eastman saying, I've decided
I should be on the pardoned list if that is still
in the works. Eastman was so sure that what he had
done was criminal and exposed him to prosecution
that he wanted a pardon from then-President
Donald Trump. These are not good people,
and they all knew it was against the law.
And there were other lawyers saying, hey,
to the group that's pushing this stuff. You need
lawyers. Remember, MAGA means making attorneys
get attorneys. And, you know, Rudy ended up with
an attorney. Michael Cohen ended up with it just
that's what it is par for the course. And they
were saying all you people should go and get
yourselves. Criminal defense attorneys. Eastman
knew and Trump was at least told incredible
revelations from the committee. Let's next talk
about this idea of hang Mike Pence. All right